thank you very much
i thought i'd start by talking about
some mail in voting that just was
revealed just the news half a million
incorrect absentee ballot applications
were sent all across
the state of virginia including to
many dead people this was an
unprecedented mailing flub
that's heightened concerns about the
integrity of expanding mail-in voting
and mail-in voting efforts it's a
disaster
all over virginia half a million votes
so that's something you have to think
about
we don't want to have a rigged election
i know that
and you have to be very careful when you
mention
as you constantly do russia or you
mention
china or you mention iran or others that
attack our
election system and when you have this
mail-in voting it's a it's very
susceptible to something that can be
easily attacked
by foreign countries and by
frankly democrats and by republicans
and i think that it's something you have
to start thinking about very seriously
our system is not equipped for it the
post office is not equipped for it
and people should vote like they did in
world war one and
world war ii and your numbers will be
in 90 days or less your numbers will be
very good i think much better on the
coronavirus or the china virus
but it's something you have to look
about look at and and say this is just
crazy this just came out half a million
incorrect
ballot applications sent all over the
state of virginia to many people that
weren't living they had some sent to
pets dogs
this is what we're going to get into and
it's going to be a disaster
and it's going to be thought of very
poorly it's going to hurt our country
after our news conference saturday night
and the pro
growth announcement we're pro jobs pro
health safety
executive orders the stock market
went up 358 points today so we
we issued those executive orders and the
stock market went up 358 points today
it's quite a reaction the dow jones
and the s p 500 are now up
50 since march 50 i think if you had
money in there if you put your money in
in march yeah 50
the nasdaq index continues to set new
records it's been up over 14 times
new record in nasdaq and
the s p 500 and the dow dow jones
are going to be i mean the way they're
going it looks like they're just about
going to be topping records hopefully
soon
excuse me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
um
so thank you very much sorry for that
the there was a shooting
outside of the white house and seems to
be very well under control i'd like to
thank the
secret service for doing their
always quick and very effective work but
there was an actual shooting
and somebody's been
taken to the hospital i don't know the
condition of the person
it seems that the person was was shot
by secret service so we'll see what
happens
and uh yeah did you have something good
there are no details we just found out
just now
it was outside of the white house this
area right over here
and they'll have details for you in a
little while
somebody is taken to the hospital it
seems that the shooting was done by law
enforcement
at that person at the suspect it was the
suspect who was shot
and this just took place a couple of
people outside
i notice a man named john roberts who
you know very well
uh he reported that he heard shots he
was outside and he heard
two shots
we don't know yet we don't know they're
they're going to fight you know if the
individual said anything sir
anything like that we don't know that it
was the secret service that did
shoot this it seems to be yeah where
were you taking mr president were you
taking to the bunker
no we're taking just out over to the
oval office
uh just told me when he came up you
pretty much saw it like i did
he said so could you please come with me
so you were surprised i was surprised
also i think it's probably pretty
unusual
but uh very very professional people
that do a fantastic job as you know
so it seems to me it seems to be from
what i was said there was
a shooting it was law enforcement
shot someone seems to be the suspect and
the suspect is now on the way to the
hospital
i can't tell you the condition of the
suspect
there was nobody else injured there was
no other law enforcement didn't you
and i just want to i will get on to the
press conference but
i do want to thank secret service they
are fantastic the job they do
uh from what i understand the answer is
yes
that's what i understand i don't know
you'll have to ask
i don't know you'll have to get they'll
have a they'll have a detailed
maybe a briefing for you outside later
i don't know i didn't ask that question
it might not have had anything to do
with me
it might have been something else but uh
it was on the outside of the premises
the wall
the uh the as you know the fencing
especially the new fencing that they put
up is
very powerful but it was on the outside
of the white house
okay and they'll have a full report
secret service
in a little while we'll have a full
report
[Music]
do i seem rattled it's uh unfortunate
that this is
a world but the world's always been
a dangerous place it's not something
that's unique
the world has been you look back over
the
centuries the world has been a dangerous
place very dangerous place and
it will continue i guess for a period of
time
does this make you think differently
about your personal safety inside the
white house
no i feel very safe with uh secret
service they're fantastic people
they're the best of the best and they're
highly trained
i don't know if anybody got to walk
outside but
there were a lot of terrific looking
people ready to go if something was
necessary
people at the highest level of law
enforcement there's nobody
like these people so they just wanted me
to step aside
for a little while just to make sure
that everything was cleared outside
because it was right in this area so
mr president why did you decide after
that because obviously it created a lot
of commotion what made you decide to
come back and continue the briefing well
i didn't even think about not coming
back i said am i able to go back and
they said you'd have to wait a little
while i waited a little while as you
know
in the oval office area and
uh i said can i get back now and they
said yes
and they have a lot of fortification
outside just in case but
it was one person okay
he said the shooting was outside how far
away from them they're going to be
giving you a full briefing in a little
while in the white house or was it right
i can only tell you they're going to
give you a briefing it was outside of
the premises
near the fence but outside of the
promises
so i was telling you that the dow jones
and the s p 500 are now 50 percent above
the march level nasdaq is
setting new records it's already broken
the record despite
the situation of having the china virus
we have
new jobs arising and unemployment is
falling faster than
nearly anyone thought and over the past
three months we've created over nine
million
jobs and that's a record a three month
record of you added up it's a three
month record by far
and we've beaten expectations by 12
million
or 12 million above expectations
which is pretty remarkable today we had
great
reports on new job openings and there's
clearly a housing boom which has been
incredible
numbers in both housing and an
automobile boom
we've rarely seen anything like it and
it's going on right now in america
inventories are at rock bottom used car
sales are at record levels
and we will have rebuilt we're doing
a rebuilding like nobody's ever seen
it's a big plus for
manufacturing and construction so
construction's
getting close to record territory
manufacturing is doing very well the car
companies are doing great
very happy for michigan the state of
michigan we have a lot of car companies
moving in a lot of plants are being
built and expanded in michigan and
ohio there is no reason why the
economy can't grow at a 20 pace in the
third quarter that would be a record
and interestingly it'll be a a number
that's going to be announced before
november 3rd
it gets announced probably around
november 1st which is
very interesting but it's it's going to
grow at a very substantial pace based on
all of the numbers we're looking at
and probably a lot more substantial than
we originally thought
we're creating new incentives for
working jobs and we're also providing
much needed assistance to those who
are still suffering from the effects of
the
pandemic contraction and the contraction
is now
well we have the pandemic we have a lot
of great things happening in terms of
the vaccines and therapeutics as you
know and
i think we'll be making tremendous
progress over the next
period of a few months and certainly
before the end of the year i think we'll
have a
vaccine before the end of the year very
substantially and we may have
a therapeutic resolvement very quickly
very very quickly and frankly that's the
one i'd rather have faster
because he'd go in he'd give a
transfusion or a shot
to people that are very ill and they'd
be able to come out of the hospital
the next day or a few days later if the
states participate in our core sharing
unemployment plan
we are going to be doing something
very very interesting with all of the
things that we announced on saturday i
have to repeat what they are you know
very well and
we've had we've had some tremendous
success already if you look at what's
happening with the stock market and
people are very thrilled at what we're
doing
we'd like to get the democrats to focus
on other than
what they're focusing on which is a
bailout of
poorly running states we have many great
running states
states that are setting records and
let's see what happens with respect to
that but the uh
we're looking at also considering a
capital gains tax cut which would create
a lot more jobs so we're looking very
seriously at a capital gains tax cut
and also at an income tax cut
for middle income families
we're looking at expanding the tax cuts
that we've already done
but specifically for middle-income
families and you'll be hearing about
that in the upcoming
few weeks and i think it'll be very
exciting so
a capital gains tax is going to be
a lot of a lot of people put to work and
it would be a cut in the capital gains
tax and also a cut in the
middle income income tax
so i now want to just discuss a little
quick brief and then we'll take a few
more questions
but uh we took some who would have known
we were going to take questions before
we started right
that right jennifer but uh that's the
way it happens sometimes we want to
discuss if
we might the china virus and the world
continues its fight
against this horrible plague countries
in every continent are seeing increases
in cases
we have a rapid increase only in cases
where it's very interesting because
we're so far ahead of testing
we have more cases if we had much
smaller testing would have fewer but we
feel that having testing is a very
important
thing it's a great it's a great record
to have in
many ways we we've tested i guess close
to 65 million people
right now and nobody's even close to
that number
no other country is close india would be
second at 11 million
and they have 1.5 billion people so we
we have the number one testing anywhere
in the world by far and
we also have i think the highest quality
test we have a lot of different ones but
we have the highest quality including
the short term and the lab tests the lab
tests take a little bit longer
and dr burks was telling me a little
while ago that
we're down to two days and two and a
half days on getting your result on the
lab test the other ones you get them in
five minutes to 15 minutes so that's
exciting but countries in every
continent are
seeing increases in cases in recent days
cases have rapidly increased in japan
and australia unfortunately
and they're now experiencing higher
peaks than they did in march
to the south of a border of our border
cases have continued to surge in mexico
central america argentina colombia peru
brazil
and throughout latin america it's really
the hot spot
it's posing a major challenge for
this continent latin america is now the
region with the
most number of confirmed cases by far
despite a
relative scarcity of testing so when you
think of that that means it's
it's pretty much on fire they're having
a hard time and we're helping them we're
sending them tremendous numbers of
ventilators which we're making by the
thousands every month
and we're helping latin america very
much it's hard for
them to come into the country because we
have big sections of wall up now the new
wall is being built which people don't
talk about they used to talk about
nothing but the wall
now that it's being built they're not
talking about it so much but it's helped
us because we're up to
almost we're getting close to 280 miles
280 miles in the most important areas
so that's helping us a lot in terms of
not having people come in to the country
who are
infected with the coronavirus
this global trend underscores the
persistence of the virus including
in nations that apply the strictest and
most punishing lockdowns you have
nations that are
really tough on the lockdowns and
they're getting hit very hard
that's why my administration is pursuing
a science-based approach that protects
the most vulnerable
preserves hospital capacity and focuses
on the delivery and development of
treatments and ultimately the vaccine
i feel strongly that we will have a
vaccine by
the end of the year and it will be put
in service
maybe even as we get it because we're
all set militarily we're using our
military to
distribute the vaccine and logistically
there's nobody like this group of people
i meet with them a lot and they're ready
to go
as soon as they have it they'll be going
but
more importantly the therapeutics as i
said i think the therapeutics could be
great initially speaking i think that
would be if i had my choice but you can
have them both
you're going to have them both you can
have them both very soon too
at the same time we urge all americans
to apply common sense
mitigation you all know what that
mitigation is everybody knows it by
heart now
nearly half of all of the deaths from
the china virus in the united states
have occurred in nursing homes and
long-term care facilities that's why we
have
delivered funding equipment and rapid
testing to our nation's
nursing homes to protect those at high
risk we're very focused on nursing homes
and senior citizens areas
anywhere that we have senior citizens
who are very very focused
we've delivered over 1800 rapid
point-of-care testing devices those are
very quick
and shipped over 700 000 tests to
nursing homes
nursing homes are being protected like
never before the united states faces a
unique range of challenges that requires
our constant vigilance
america has the largest at-risk
population of any developed country
by far 1.5 million residents of nursing
homes about five times out of the united
kingdom and other european countries our
country also has a higher
prevalence of underlying conditions that
this virus targets
yet we have fewer deaths per capita than
the united kingdom
and most other peer nations in western
europe
so that's an important we have fewer
deaths per capita than the united
kingdom and most other
nations in western europe and heading
for
even stronger numbers but one person is
too much as far as i'm concerned should
have never been allowed to happen
should have never been allowed to escape
china nationwide we continue to see
encouraging signs in the last seven days
nationwide cases declined by 14
hospitalizations decreased by 7
fatalities decreased by 9 percent
arizona and florida are improving
rapidly with fewer patients coming to
emergency rooms by far as well as
decreasing cases decreasing fatalities
unexpected
and expanded hospital capacities so
we have an expanded hospital capacity
it's it's pretty dramatic when you look
at it meaning we have more room
should we need it so a lot of
tremendous work has been done in texas
likewise the number of patients
going to emergency rooms has dropped
from july
by more than two-thirds that's a lot
nevertheless we continue to monitor
texas
very closely terrific governor terrific
people working on that
whole situation in texas especially
at its test positivity rate
which rose over 20 percent this weekend
overall
cases in texas are coming down and have
stabilized
in the border counties that's again
where you have
the wall and you're next to uh in in
some cases the wall in some cases you'll
have it very shortly you'll have it all
built within a number of months but
those areas were hit very hard
and they're likely cases from mexico
that come in back and forth from the
border they come in illegally
as doctors have found more effective
ways to treat patients the fatality rate
continues to improve
texas has won six the fatality rate of
new york and new jersey
that they had in april and the if you
look at new york and new jersey they
work very very hard but
very heavy density and a lot of
different kinds of difficulty
the fatality rates in florida and
arizona are between 25 and 33 percent of
the peak rates
of new york and new jersey again
different
different climate a different grouping
different density tremendously different
density
in california the situation is starting
to stabilize and improve throughout the
major metropolitan areas statewide
hospitalizations continue to decline
very substantially with about 20 percent
fewer
in patients now than on july 21st
california is starting to really show
signs of uh
correcting we're monitoring regions with
increasing cases including boston
chicago
and the midwest and we're monitoring
them very very strongly and
very very hard i i do want to say that
i think at the end of a fairly short
period of time you're going to be in
very
very good shape all over our country
every loss of life is tragic and all
nations must work together to defeat
this horrible virus
my administration is going to continue
to save as many lives as possible we are
working
round the clock everybody it's uh
incredible how hard they're working and
uh people from other countries we're
working with them also and they're
working very hard this is something
that's now attacked 188 different
countries
there are a wide range of factors that
determine how the virus impacts a nation
such as age underlining conditions
underlying conditions is a very big one
if you're sick in any way if you're if
especially they say heart and diabetes
that's not a good
thing to have if you uh
if you're going to have this if you're
going to catch it so we're trying to
protect especially those people that
have
problems with their heart or diabetes
and levels of pre-existing immunity
resulting from
past exposure to other viruses which
happens
we must stop politicizing the virus and
instead be
united in our condemnation of
how this virus came to america how this
virus came to the world
and we're going to figure it out and
we're going to find out and we're very
angry about it
on the therapeutics and vaccine updates
three vaccine candidates are currently
in
phase three clinical trials something
that would have been impossible
under the previous administration or any
other administration
and several others are showing
considerable promise
we have great companies very well known
companies i think everyone in this room
would know these companies but they're
the biggest and the best in the world
and we're working with uh other
foreign companies and countries that
have
have been really working very closely
with us we're trading we're not looking
to
do anything but come up with the answer
and we really don't we don't care we
want to come up with the answer
if it's one of ours or one of theirs
it's okay we have to come up with the
answer and we're
very close to getting it some people
think we have it
we may have it we have the best
scientists in the world racing to
develop a safe vaccine that will end
this pandemic
save millions of lives and that's
millions of lives all over the world
and end the harm inflicted by this virus
to our society
and to all other nations last week the
nih began a clinical trial of
rem de severe paired with another
approved antiviral drug
and anti-inflammatory drug you know that
rem deserver has been very successful
and now they're experimenting with
others
including antivirals and
anti-inflammatories
and they're having some very interesting
success
we've secured enough room desevere to
treat over 650 000 patients
on saturday i took executive action
in its signing to save american jobs and
support american workers i signed
directives to give a payroll tax
holiday with the understanding that
after the election on the assumption
that it would be
victorious for an administration that's
done a great job
we will be ending that tax we'll be
terminating that tax
on the other hand the other group wants
to raise taxes and they may want to
leave it
where you pay it but the payroll tax is
a big deal for people
it's a tremendous saving for people and
we're
going to be doing it and we intend to
terminate it
at the end of the appropriate period of
time
it's for those making less than one
hundred thousand dollars through the end
of 2020
to provide an extra 400 per week also
in unemployment benefits and to extend
the freeze on home evictions
we want to extend the freeze so people
aren't evicted it's not their fault that
the
virus came from china it's china's fault
and to suspend payments
on student loans through the end of the
year and then beyond
and again you know they're paying
interest on loans and and they're not
allowed to go to their college
so we're going to suspend payments on
student loans
through the end of the year and then
another extension most likely because
it's
not fair to the students to to have to
pay
when the colleges aren't doing the job
of getting open
and i think probably many of them could
be open so i want to thank you all i'm
sorry for the disturbance before
things happen and uh if you'd like we
take a few questions yeah thank you mr
president i appreciate it
um haley said earlier today that you've
been working around the clock
so there's no delay to get these um
enhancement unemployment payments to
americans
can you give me your timetable are we
talking next week two weeks a month
so mr secretary you're saying when i
think within the next week or two
most of the states will be able to
execute got it the way
gentlemen you know everybody you know
russell you know
but this is scott atlas you know that
scott is a very famous man who's uh
also very uh highly respected stanford
and he's working with us and will be
working with us on the coronavirus
and he has many great ideas and
he thinks what we've done is really good
and now we'll take it to a new level
and so it's great to have scott working
along with us and we appreciate it very
much scott thank you very much
really we've had some great discussions
on that mr president if you don't mind
you mentioned
the states have all the governors sign
on to this
uh we just had a meeting with the
governors and they were
very anxious to get money for the people
in their states
and if they uh depending on the state we
have the right to do
what we want to do we can terminate the
25 percent
uh or we don't have to do that so we'll
see what it is depends on the individual
state
but a lot of money will be going to a
lot of people very quickly
and i've instructed the secretary of the
treasury to
move as quickly as he can right so we'll
get it done yeah please
i wanted to just ask you to be clear on
the incident
outside there's a fairly significant
perimeter around
the white house it doesn't concern you
at all that someone who is armed was
able to get
so close that you needed to be removed
from the briefing room well i don't know
if he was close or not he or she
i don't know if it was a he or she but
i have such confidence in these people
they're so good
and i don't think the person breached
anything
it was on the outside ground so i don't
believe anything was breached i asked
that question
so they were relatively far away
97 000 children tested positive for
coronavirus in the last two weeks in
july according to the
american academy of pediatrics does that
give you any pause about
schools reopening for in-person learning
because
they may have as you would call it a
case it may be a case but it's
also a case where there's a tiny it's a
tiny fraction
of uh death tiny fraction
and uh they get better very quickly
yeah they have they may have it for a
short period of time but that as you
know the
the seriousness of it in terms of what
it leads to is
is extraordinarily small very very much
less
than one percent
yeah i think that for the most part they
do very well i mean they
they don't get very sick they don't
catch it easily they don't get
very sick and according to the people
that i've spoken to they don't
transport it or transfer it to other
people
or certainly not very easily so yeah i
think schools have to open
we want to get our economy going we have
incredible numbers despite this
if we could get this going i think it's
a very important thing for the economy
to get the schools
going john i think thank you mr
president uh in ohio a few days ago
you said quote joe biden has hurt god
he's against god the vice president has
said that he's a man of deep catholic
faith that he's
credited for helping him endure some
immense personal tragedy
so sir what did you mean by that when
you say that your bible has hurt god or
is against god well if you look at the
manifesto that
that they've come up with and if you
look at their stance on religion
and things having to do very importantly
with aspects of religion and faith
i don't think a man of deep religion
would be agreeing to the bernie sanders
plan
you take a look at what they have in and
you just
you can't put that into the realm of
a religious group of people i will say
that
and i think it's one of the reasons why
if you look at polls which
i'm not a big believer in polls i
wouldn't if i was i guess i wouldn't be
standing here right now
and by the way our poll numbers are
going up very rapidly as you know and
joe's are going down very rapidly he'll
have to come out of the basement it
looks like pretty soon
because that uh you know it's one of
those things but no if you look at
the manifesto i call it the manifesto a
lot of people are calling it the
manifesto
my opinion it's further left than where
bernie was before so normally he'd be
left and you'd bring it somewhere a
little bit toward the center
but some of the things that they have
down there and i'm not
only talking in terms of religion i'm
not talking even
in terms of religion but some of the
things they have in the agreement made
and this was an agreement made by bernie
sanders and
joe uh it's a terrible thing it would be
a terrible thing for our country
it will destroy our country we will go
into a depression
we will put on regulation we will double
and triple taxes
we will it will be terrible for health
care just terrible you'll have 180
million people lose their health care
it will be a terrible terrible thing for
our country okay yeah please jeff
thank you sir i'd like to ask you a
question about something you said in
fedminster as well
he said that you're planning to issue an
executive order
to ensure that health insurance
companies prevent or
cover people with pre-existing
conditions and you said that
that had never been done before but
that's that's not the case because that
is
the law under the affordable care act so
my question is
why do you need to issue an executive
order for law that has already existed
i said as an executive order i as you
said
said as an executive order it hasn't
been done before we want to
we want to be able to assure people
that pre-existing condition is always
taken care of
as you know we've done tremendous things
having to do with the individual
mandate we got rid of the individual
mandate from obamacare which really
ended obamacare as it would be
officially known because the individual
mandate was the biggest part
it was also the most unpopular part
where you pay
for a terror terrible privilege of
overpaying
for insurance you pay not to have to pay
for your health care
and that was a disaster for people at a
very unpopular that was
called the individual mandate and we
terminated that
and officially terminated that and that
was something that
we have been given uh thanks for by many
many people
but the individual mandate will always
be
with us the the individual mandate
termination will always be they can't
start it up in fact i don't even believe
you'll have to tell me i don't believe
it's been challenged when we ended it
and pre-existing conditions the
republicans are
100 percent there and i'll be
issuing at some point in the not too
distant future a very strong statement
on that
probably in the form of an executive
order why do you need
to do an executive order if it's already
a part of it just a double safety net
and just to let people know that the
republicans are totally
strongly in favor of pre-existing
condition
taking care of people with pre-existing
conditions
it's a it's a signal to people
it's a second it's a second platform
we have pre-existing conditions will be
taken care of 100
by republicans and the republican party
i think it's a
i actually think it's a very important
statement yes please mr president do you
still intend to try to hold an in-person
g7
meeting uh in the united states at some
point in august and september and have
you already sent out invitations to do
so we haven't sent out invitations we're
talking to them as you know i was on the
phone with many of them yesterday with
respect to lebanon
which is truly one of the saddest most
catastrophic things i've ever seen
and they have no idea how many people
have died they're having
revolution right now in that country
it's just a terrible thing
and but i was yesterday eight o'clock in
the morning we had a
hour time we had a a big teleconference
call some of those people were there
i i'm much more inclined to do it
sometime after the election
we were going to do it in september
they'd like to do it
we could do it through teleconference or
we could do it through a meeting but
i i sort of am now suggesting i told my
people
yesterday actually uh why do we do it
sometime after the
election when things are a little bit uh
you have a little more time to think
about it because it's very important
the g7 is very important uh to that
meeting
uh i don't know but we have invited a
number of people to the meeting
i certainly would invite him to the
meeting i think he's an important factor
but we will invite certain people that
aren't in the g7
some people have already accepted but
we're going to be doing it after the
election i think it's a better
atmosphere to have a g7 i think it's a
lot
uh i think it's just a better calmer
atmosphere to have a g7 yeah please
thank you uh i wanted to ask secretary
mahish actually
uh have you spoken to any democrats
since friday or they reached out to you
at all about
restarting negotiations
i have not spoken to schumer since then
do you expect would you reach out at all
to
they're them to negotiate and have a new
proposal we're more than happy to meet
they're hurting people very badly this
would have been so easy for them to do
and i saw that senator schumer said
today on
a show i don't know which show but he
said today on the show that
we should meet we should do something
but you know where has he been for how
many
weeks have you been negotiating like
four and
uh they should do something would have
been so much easier than
doing it the way we did it but we did
something that's uh
very important and frankly it's been
well received very well received go
ahead please
thank you mr president you tweeted
earlier today that you're considering
gettysburg as a venue for your speech
for the rnc nominated acceptance
what's your thinking behind that as a
possible location well i think it's i've
been to
gettysburg numerous times it's a
national park it's a national
historic site it's incredible
you know it's the history it's
incredible actually to me
uh it was a very important place and is
a very important place in our country
so we're looking at that and we're
looking at the white house the white
house would be
very much easier for secret service you
see
what just went on here they're all here
just like you have your seats they have
their seats at the white house
so there wouldn't be any expense or any
extraordinary expense
and the white house would be a lovely
place to do it all so least expensive
place that you could do it would be at
the white house
if this is a government a government
expense and i you know look i
i watch also with governments i watch to
make sure that
we do what's right but we're looking at
gettysburg and we're looking at the
white house and
we have other sites too but i think
these would be two really beautiful sets
jennifer
would you envision having an audience
for that speech
you could you have plenty of room at
both locations i see john roberts john
uh you were outside you said you heard
shots fired before
two shots in rapid succession just after
you picked up yours
and they were shots pretty much
certainly you definitely know the
difference i know that
that's you know the difference you
thought they were shots john
definitely sounded like i saw your
report inside when i went inside
uh it's a good report too thank you very
much appreciate it
uh can you give jennifer please update
on
china do you think that your
administration will respond
to the sanctions that china announced
this morning on
american officials well we've already
responded in many different ways where
we're uh talking a lot about
china we shouldn't have been talking
about china we did a phase one deal and
it was
a wonderful deal and all of a sudden it
means
very little in the overall import of
things
they should have never allowed what
happened to the world including us
but this was released into europe and it
was released into the u.s and it was
released all throughout the world but it
wasn't released into china
and we were doing numbers that will you
know just were incredible
and we hope to be able to do them
perhaps even next year i think we're
gonna have an incredible year next year
but
that will never pay for the loss of life
in our country and all over the world so
we are
we view china differently than we did
eight months ago
very much differently yes please is
there still any consideration of
de-listing chinese companies
is that an ongoing discussion de-listing
chinese companies we never comment on
specific things but no there's nothing
still on the table there's no again
nothing specifically at the moment
are you talking about deep listing
comments on the exchange yes oh
i'm sorry yes so just to be clear we did
make the recommendation
and the sec will be putting out yes as
as
of the end of next year
if they do not fully comply and that's
chinese companies any other companies
they all have to comply with the same
exact accounting
where they will be listed on the
exchanges
and jennifer we're also talking on the
wto
the world trade organization china is
treated much differently than we
are this should have been handled many
years ago when it
first happened but they are treated as a
uh
as a nation that's developing they're
treated as what they call a developing
nation which gives them tremendous
incentives and advantages over and above
what the united states gets and
over and above what other countries get
also this is a developing nation i don't
think so i don't think for purposes of
what we're talking about it should be
and we are putting in and we've already
put in a request that
china should no longer be declared a
developing nation and have advantages
over
the u.s and i told them that a year ago
and i told them that two years ago and
we put it in very powerfully
that they should not have advantages
over
other countries frankly and sure they're
not going to have any more advantages
over this should have been done
by numerous presidents a long time ago
because it gives them a tremendous
a tremendous boost over everybody else
and it's a very unfair situation
no we are upset with china because of
what they did
china was not good and china will be
if you look at what's going to happen
whether it's iran
uh iran will make a deal with us in a
month
after the election's over if we win the
election but the
greatest dream in the world is that joe
biden wins because they will own this
country china will own this country
north korea will own this country they
will own our country
and they're all waiting to see the
election and if we make a
if we have a win in on november 3rd we
will
have a deal with in my opinion iran
within one month
and i don't know that we want to have a
deal with china to be honest with you so
i'm saying to myself gee
but china wants us to lose very badly
and you know who else is not happy with
us winning russia the phony
people that tell the story the fake news
stories about russia
it was just reported the numbers uh i
raised
400 billion dollars extra in nato you
know that it
went from 130 to 400 billion dollars and
that's a year
in order to strengthen up nato nobody
says that
we became the biggest energy exporter we
are now
if you look at what we have we're energy
independent so many different things our
military
is stronger than it ever was we spent
2.5 trillion dollars on our military
i exposed the terrible deal between
germany and
russia on the pipeline nobody even knew
about the pipeline nordstrom nordstrom
2.
nobody knew about it nobody talks about
it i said what's this all about so we
protect
germany from russia and germany pays
russia billions of dollars a year for
energy
and it's a big portion of germany's
energy
if i was a person that was a german
citizen i would not be happy with that
deal
because they're at a very big
disadvantage so
no russia would not be happy and i can
tell you
that china would not be happy at all
we've taken in
tens of billions of dollars as you're
head of the treasury
steve right we've taken in tens of
billions of dollars from
china we never took 10 cents from china
never not even 10 cents and
28 billion dollars we gave to our
farmers because they were targeted by
china
they were actually targeted and we gave
28 billion dollars
compliments of china to our great
farmers
and ranchers because they were unfairly
targeted by china
in order to make a better deal with us i
said we're not going to do that we're
going to instead of making a better deal
we're going to tariff you
at very high numbers 25 10 and actually
numbers that could
go up a lot and uh we had a lot of money
left over
after giving the 28 billion to to the
farmers and ranchers and
some others frankly we uh we had
many many billions of dollars left over
and we're still receiving that money
even though we made the deal we're still
receiving that money
so if uh if we win the election we'll
have deals with
a lot of countries very fast they're
just waiting to see who wins because
they are hoping they are hoping
that joe biden wins sleepy joe and if he
wins you know what's going to happen
china will own us our markets will crash
the 401ks will go down to practically
nothing stocks will go down to
practically nothing remember stocks
there's these big companies they're
owned by millions of people
that are carpenters and policemen and
farmers and lots of other people and and
uh
they are the ones that benefit by having
a good stock market probably more than
anybody else
but the 401ks the stocks the economy
will be
in a shambles they want to raise taxes
they want to triple
taxes they want to raise the corporate
tax but they want to raise all taxes
ultimately they can't pay for what they
want to do anyway and what they're going
to do is
destroy your health care and destroy so
many other things we're going to have
180
million people that are so happy with
their private health care they're going
to lose it
under this crazy plan that these people
are proposing so
you will have a crash like you've never
seen before and i've been very
i've been very good at predicting these
things yeah please guys thank you thank
you mr president uh you just mentioned
uh president putin and possibility of
inviting him here because he's important
um your own director of national
intelligence has said that russia is
currently planning or actually meddling
in the election
have you raised that directly with putin
ever they said that china
russia iran and probably others
but because of the fake news they seem
to think russia plays the best
so what they do it's all right well i'm
just saying the way the politicians look
the other day they said the three
countries they said china
and russia and iran and some reporter
got up and said
russia is meddling i said well didn't it
mention china and iran why didn't you
mention them too
so so i don't know you know what i'm
telling you i'll tell you who's meddling
in our elections
the democrats are meddling by wanting
and insisting on sending mail-in ballots
where there's corruption all over the
place if you check what happened in new
york a small
relatively small race with carolyn
maloney
and they called her the winner the other
day because i was mentioning it
at conferences and getting a lot of
action on that statement
so they called her they declared her the
winner and they have no idea who won
and the person her opponent is very
angry but they had mail-in
voting and they had hundreds and i think
even thousands of ballots that are
missing
that were fraudulent take a look at the
carolyn maloney race take a look at
patterson new jersey take a look now at
this one in virginia where they mailed
out
500 000 applications and they're going
to people
that aren't supposed to be getting an
application
yeah please go ahead thank you sir
secretary pompeo is heading to europe
again
this week do you have any updates on
when the
travel restrictions of the eu are going
to be listed it seems strange we're
offering exemptions for professional
athletes but not the k-1 visa holders
the so-called well we're trying to do
the best we can you have big
sporting events and that's good for our
economy that's good for us and they do
talk about certain exemptions and they
make sure everyone's perfectly tested
and everyone comes in
100 but you know we do make certain
accommodations because you do have star
athletes and that means a good thing for
the country that's economic development
etc uh but we are working very closely
with europe and with other countries to
see what's the best timing don't forget
i was the one that
turned europe off because they really uh
they led the way
they let it much more so than we did we
were months following them
and uh in terms of they got hit earlier
than we did
quite a bit earlier than we did so i put
the restrictions on europe i put the
restrictions on china which was a great
thing to do in retrospect we're getting
i mean that's that was a very important
day dr fauci said that was one of the
most important days
and a lot of people didn't want me to do
it but we first put ban a ban on anybody
from china coming in and then we put
a ban on europe coming in but we're
working very closely with europe to see
when that will all come off yeah please
if 160 000 people had died on president
obama's watch do you think you would
have called for his resignation
no i wouldn't have done that i think
it's
i think it's been amazing what we've
been able to do if we didn't close up
our country we would have had
one and a half or two million people
already did
we've called it right now we don't have
to close it we understand the disease
nobody understood it because
nobody's ever seen anything like this
the closest thing is uh
in 1917 they say right the the great the
great pandemic
certainly was a terrible thing where
they lost anywhere from 50 to 100
million people
probably ended the second world war all
the soldiers were sick
uh it was a that was a terrible
situation
and this is highly contagious this one
is highly highly contagious
now if i would have listened to a lot of
people we would have kept it open
and by the way we keep it open now all
the way we keep it open
but we would have kept it open and you
could be up to a million and a half or
two million people right now
one and a half to two million people uh
our people have done a fantastic jobs
our consultants and our doctors you know
and
with disagreements and with a lot of
things happening what we've done with
ventilators has been amazing what we've
done with
medical equipment has been incredible
we've supplied the governor's nobody
not one person in this country that
needed a ventilator didn't get it
and you know at the beginning there was
a big shortage of ventilators nobody had
stockpiles or anything
comparable to what you had to have so uh
we would have lost if you think about it
you had mentioned 160
000 people multiply that times 10 right
now
i think it would have been unsustainable
and unacceptable
but that's what would have happened had
we kept it open so
uh no i think we're a very large country
we are one person i said all the
time a lot of people like to leave that
out one person is too many it should
have never happened
but they've done a really an
extraordinary job they'll never be given
the credit and i'm not talking about me
the people that have worked on this so
hard will never be given the credit but
they've done an extraordinary job with a
very large diverse
country really an extraordinary job and
a lot of the governors who
as you know they sort of do the micro
in their states and they go up and i
think i can tell you that a lot of the
governors have done an extraordinary job
too yeah please go ahead
thank you did you ask the u.s ambassador
in brazil to focus his
efforts in uh eliminating ethanol
tariffs
in brazil you have to you can't yeah
ambassador in brazil to focus his
efforts to lower to eliminate
ethanol tariffs in brazil we haven't
really discussed that too much but
at some point we probably will be and we
don't want
people tariffing us and if they tariff
us although i must tell you have a very
good
relationship with president bolsonaro
he's great he's and i hear he's doing
well he's recovered from
having covid having coveted 19 as they
say
and that's great and send in my regards
i think that as far as brazil is
concerned if they do tariffs
we have to have an equalization of
tariffs and we
we are going to be presenting something
having to do with tariffs and fairness
and
tariffs because we have many countries
for many years that have been charging
us tariffs
to do business and we don't charge them
and it's called
reciprocity it's called reciprocal
tariffs
and uh you may be seeing something on
that very soon did you have one oh yeah
oh yeah thank you mr president first of
all thank you for coming back
to finish the briefing thank you very
much scuffle
um so i have an opinion question for you
joe biden is set to announce his running
mate
at any time now we expect him to
announce
her um many of your supporters feel
that the reason that obama's former nsa
susan rice is at the top of biden's list
is that she can best cover up a lot of
the obamacare surveillance crimes that
have taken place
during your campaign what are your
thoughts what is your opinion do you
do you subscribe to that line of thought
how do you feel about it
well look uh the obama campaign spied on
our campaign and they've been caught all
right and now let's see what happens to
them
but they have been caught they've been
caught red-handed
it's probably treason it's a horrible
thing they did
it probably never happened before at
least nobody
got caught doing it but they use the
intelligence agencies of our country
to spy on my campaign and they have been
caught
and there are a lot of people involved
i don't want to say how much she's
involved frankly if he chooses her
that's fine but that's a potential
liability
we'll see but president obama knew about
it
joe biden knew about it comey
knew about it brennan clapper the whole
group
they all knew about it lisa page and
her lover struck they all knew about it
and we have it documented we have it in
texts we have it in all sorts of forms
they knew about it it was a terrible
thing should have never happened and
should never be allowed to happen again
to a president this should never happen
again this was a
set up like we have never seen i think
it's the political crime of the century
and
they've been caught so let's see what
happens to them all thank you very much
thank you thank you